if you don't stand tall and just let
stuff happen y'all ain't got no control
anyway so you think you think okay let's
say the game is already planned and
ready ready to go and it give you the
announcement y'all think on Twitter
y'all saying I don't want my high five
who the hell high five rush it ain't
your high five rush but y sitting here
it's not your high five Rush apparently
it's everybody's high five Rush yeah for
the it ain't nobody's high five rush but
Xbox high five Rush right now now you
this sky falling mentality everything's
over there already you done gave up you
done said here take my lunch and he take
my car keys too and drive home I'm sorry
I'm sorry come on now